foreign
[Music]
and welcome to the next end game video
in the previous set of videos we talked
about pawn and games and today is an
exciting day because we are moving away
from Pawn and games and toward uh the
next type of end game we start adding
material to the board and the subject of
the next two videos is going to be king
and Knight versus King and pawn end
games these are end games in which one
side has a king a knight and or pawns
and the other side has only a king and
or pawns so we are putting under the
microscope the battle between the Knight
and the pawns and the Knight of course
is notorious for being very very bad at
dealing with past pawns and this is one
of the reasons that this type of end
game is so important to study and
understand whether you are the side that
has the Knight or the side that has the
pawns I think it occurs pretty
frequently in my experience and
unfortunately is given very scant
coverage in chess literature the direct
scan game manual which is sort of the
end game Bible
devotes something like two or three
pages to this type of end game I mean
the examples are pretty haphazardly
selected so there's a lot to know in
these types of end games
um and I have done my best to select all
of the important positions I will break
them down very carefully and in the
subsequent video we are going to put
your theoretical knowledge to use with a
set of practical examples it's actually
a fascinating type of end game that
gives rise to some really entertaining
end game tactics so there's really a lot
to break down a lot to get to this is
going to be a pretty wild video because
we are going to go through a lot of
examples and so without further Ado
let's jump in I want to say a few words
before we address our first position
about how this video is going to be
structured so the way that I've decided
to do it is as follows we will start
with a set of theoretical positions that
you have to know whether you're the side
with the Knight or the side of the Pawn
in particular we're going to talk about
the scenario in which one side has a
king and a pawn the other side has a
king in the night and the pawn has
reached the seventh ring so we will
discuss how the behavior of the position
changes depending on which file the pawn
is on and we will discuss every scenario
area I'll tell you if it's if it's
winning or drawn and we'll talk a little
bit about how both sides should proceed
and this I think forms the backbone for
all of these end games because not only
are these end games important in their
own right but they also serve as kind of
Target positions if you rewind the tape
a little bit a lot of King and Knight
versus King and pawn end games they
ultimately end up reaching some form of
this situation where one side has a Pawn
on the seventh and is trying to knock
the Knight off with the king so I think
this is a good jumping off point and
then the video will be further broken
down into several segments we'll talk
about handling the Knight and trying to
win situations in which you have the
Knight and are trying to draw against
the pawns then we take the side of the
pawns we talk about situations where you
defeat the Knight with your pawns and
then situations where you use uh your
pawns or even sometimes your bear King
in order to pull off a draw so once
again I'm expecting a long video but as
always I'm gonna try to proceed feed
with kind of a focus on really making
everything clear and understandable so
get your favorite beverage whether it's
coffee or tea or or something stronger
strap yourselves in and let's dive into
some theoretical positions so we start
with a scenario in which one side has a
corner Pawn on the seventh ring and it's
important to understand at the outset
that when I talk about the a pawn the
same thing applies also to the H Pawn
the the chessboard is symmetrical so A
and H pawns behave the same way
obviously G and B pawns behave the same
way the same with the bishop pawns and
the same with the center files so we
don't actually need to discuss several
different types of scenarios in fact as
you will see we only need to discuss
three because in the context of Knight
versus Pawn positions uh if you have a c
Pawn through an F Pawn the behavior of
the position is exactly the same so you
don't need to look at it separately okay
so in this scenario why does a pawn that
has reached A7 and the Knight is
stopping it from C7
another final important clarification is
that we are discussing scenarios where
uh the defending side's king is too far
away from the pawn obviously if the
black king is on C6 or on B7 and is
stopping the pawn itself then everything
I say is null and void because the
presence of the Knight is irrelevant uh
so that's why I put the King on H1 in
this situation but as we will see even
if the king is incredibly far away from
the pawn there is a defensive mechanism
where you actually sacrifice your knight
and try to bring your king in in time
but that is not possible here as we will
see when you have a Pawn on A7 the
Knight is the worst at stopping the
corner Pawn so of all the past pawns you
can have you actually want to have the
corner pawn and the reason is very
simple Knights are terrible at stopping
past Pawns in general because of their
limited range of motion their awkward
mobility and the fact that they simply
cannot multitask because they're a short
range piece you could have a bishop on
G2 and it could be stopping the
promotion Square doing a you know 10
million other things but also that
Bishop on G2 can move around from one
side of the board to the other so if you
approach it with your king it can Scurry
away like a cockroach back to A8 the
Knight can't do the same thing and
that's why this particular position is
winning and in most cases winning for
the side with the corner pawn and the
method is very simple you simply
approach the Knight with your king very
carefully as we'll see and what
eventually happens is that the Knight
runs out of squares on which it can stop
the pawn and ultimately gets trapped so
what you do is first of all you go King
B3 or King T3 of course you have to
avoid getting four so King C3 would be
very sloppy on account of Knight B5
check and black picks up the past Pawn
so this is true of any situation where
you're playing against the Knight you
always have to keep tabs on the
potential night Fork so we start with
King B3 we zigzag our way past the
landmine black approaches with their own
King King to C4 you can also go King B4
that doesn't matter k C5 and the King
reaches C6 in time it attacks the Knight
the Knight is only one available Square
on which it can stop the corner pawn it
has to go back to A8 and then of course
you play King B7 trapping the Knight
this is such a common scenario in these
end games the Knight simply has no
available squares there's no real estate
on the left side of the board all black
can try to do is walk back with the King
and what you should notice is that black
actually ends up being only one tempo
away from drawing the game if black if
the king moves like a knight then black
would play King C7 here we discussed
that type of position in the pawn end
game video here black is one tempo short
King C6 King B8 and white promotes the
pawn so in the scenario with the corner
Pawn on the seventh you win the game
provided that your opponent's king is
too far away from itself stopping the
past Pawn so this is the best pawn to
have when you are dealing with a knight
the a pawn and the H Pawn is both a
blessing and a curse it really depends
on the type of end game if it's King in
Pawn versus King than normally having
the corner Pawn is the worst scenario
here you generally want to have a corner
Pawn because the Knight doesn't have
access to the left side of the board
that it can use to stop the pawn Now we
move on to the scenario with the b or
the G pawn and again everything I say
about the b-pawn also applies of course
to the g-pawn
ETC now here I have brought the white
king a little bit closer because you
kind of get the point the king will
eventually Reach This square and this
position is a draw so Shifting the pawn
once one file to the right actually
favors the Knight and the reason is as
follows white starts by trying to kick
the Knight away from its control over
the B8 Square much like you do with the
corner Pawn the Knight has to hop back
to B8 and this is the chief difference
after you play the move King C7 the
Knight still has one file that it can
jump to and maintain its control over
the promotion Square the Knight can jump
out to a with a check and white can
continue pursuing the night but it can
never kick the night away
from its control over the square you can
go King B6 the Knight goes back to B8
obviously if you go the other way if you
go King A7 then the Knight can go either
to C6 or to D7 and white has achieve
nothing and if you go to C7 then uh the
moves are repeated you can go to C8 but
in no circumstance can you kick the
Knight away forcibly from its control
over the promotion Square so this
position is a draw
um and one other important clarification
will uh talk about that shortly after we
complete this initial discussion uh the
fact that white can continuously pursue
the Knight is a unique property of the
night Pawn you can continue attacking
the knight uh and continue repeating
moves in this way now what you will see
when we shift the pawn one further
Square to the right we're talking now
about the bishop Pawn the center pawn
and those pawns behave in exactly the
same way so everything I'm about to say
about the C Pawn is also true uh with
respect to the d-pawn the epon and of
course the F Pawn here's what happens
White's mechanism ism is always the same
you approach the night again the Knight
has to come back to ca here you go King
D7 and black actually has an additional
option on top of playing Knight B6 which
is much the same Escape mechanisms that
we saw with the Knight Pawn black can
actually go knight uh C8 to A7 and
what's important about this is that
white cannot continue pursuing the
Knight without losing a bunch of Tempe
of course white can go King D6 first of
all black can forcibly removed the pawn
from the board here in order to avoid
that white has to take an even more
circuitous route with King E6 this in
turn this just makes no sense and the
vast majority of situations because
black can use those extra Tempe uh to to
do something productive like move his
King back so white can eventually get to
the Knight but it takes you a bunch of
Tempe and the hilarious thing is that
black does the exact same thing on the
other side 97 rather than Knight D6
check and white can repeat the process
but by this point it's too late so this
essentially forces white to promote the
pawn and if you have no other pawns on
the board then obviously this is still a
draw but you can add upon to the board
and then you will see the chief
difference between the night pawn and
The Bishop's slash Center Pawn so let's
examine that scenario let's add a black
pawn to the board and see how the
situation changes here I've added a G7
Pawn to the board now with white to move
using your newly acquired knowledge of
how the knight in the pawn behaves in
this situation try to give an assessment
of the position is white drawing or is
black able to win I'll and you can pause
the video for a second
so the answer is that this position is
still a draw despite the presence of a
pass Pawn on G7 and the reason why is
because the king is able to continuously
pursue the Knight back and forth you go
King B5 uh Knight be at it should also
mention that Knight C7 check here uh
this actually loses the game because you
go King B6 the Knight can give another
check but we'll talk about this a little
bit later the King has to sidestep all
the potential Forks King C5 would allow
the Knight to drop back to C7 and you
see this so often you promote a queen
and then you get forked with Knight A6
in the next video uh we'll we'll really
get into the weeds of these types of
tactical ideas but what you should know
now is that white wins the game with
King to C6 and whichever way the Knight
goes the king follows it 97 King D7
Knight before check King B5 and in both
cases black cannot stop the pass Pawn so
that would be on wise white black has to
go Knight B8 white approaches the Knight
black starts pushing their Pawn and
here's the Rob Buick C7 now black
continues pushing you take the Knight
you step away and you promote that's
still a draw and if black plays Knight
A6 you go back to B6 and you know the
drill and you go backwards and forwards
black essentially cannot buy a Tempo but
now let's shift things one file over to
the right exact same position except now
white has a bishop pawn and again the
same thing would apply if White had
let's say a d-pawn or an E Pawn here
black actually wins why because after
you try to do the same thing black uses
the mechanism we just discussed black
starts pushing their pawn and whichever
way you go the Knight goes either to A7
or in the other case to E7 and white
isn't able to keep pursuing the Knight
all that white can do is helplessly
promote the pawn black takes it with the
Knight King takes E8 and black of course
promotes the G Pawn so in your mind you
should know that having the corner Pawn
is the best case scenario having the
Knight Pawn is the second best and then
the quote-unquote worst past Pawn to
have is is normally all of the files in
the center see through the F files now
there's one more important theoretical
position to know we're going to move the
pawn back one square and talk about what
happens when you have an A or an H Pawn
on the sixth rank now if you have any
other Pawn on the six rank such as a
Bishop's Pawn well obviously that is a
draw because it's still a draw with a
pawn in the seventh rank this type of
position is important to know because
it's super common and the behavior of
the Knight here is pretty unique this is
actually contrary to a lot of people's
intuition is still a draw now why is it
a draw it appears that you can easily
take the Knight away from its control
over the H7 Square by playing the move
King G7 okay but the problem is that the
Knight can use well-timed checks and the
idea of forking the pawn to nonetheless
stay in the within the range of control
of the H7 Square watch how black does
this black gives the check on E6
if you go to F7 the Knight stops the
pawn from G5 and the first important
detail is that if you play King G6 black
has to lose control over the H7 square
but he keeps it tactically Knight back
to E6 and do you see the point if you
play H7 black drops back to f8 and picks
up the pawn with a knight if you go King
F6 the Knight circles around and you
simply cannot take away all of the
knight's key squares of control Knight
f8 if King F7 Knight H7 if King G7
Knight G5 King G6 we again reach the
scenario that we just talked about with
96 so whichever way the King goes here
the Knight either has a check on G5 or
it sits on E6 and prepares to Fork the
pawn or it moves back to f8 or finally
it moves to H7 and this is the sort of
thing you can play around with yourself
to really develop a better understanding
of how it works but what you should know
now is that if you have an H Pawn on the
six rank unless the Knight is uh
improperly positioned and will address
that scenario separately the evaluation
is a draw the Knight is able to stop a
corner Pawn if it is on the six right
but not if it is on the seventh so those
are the important theoretical positions
with one side having a king and a pawn
and the other side having a king and the
Knight now let's move on to sort of the
second part of the video where we first
take the side of the pawn and we talk
about a couple of very important
scenarios in which the side with the
king and the pawn is able to win the
game and is able to surmount uh the dog
get resistance of the Knight and the
first important idea that I want to
discuss is what I have referred to as
the Sharon promotion and the Sharon
promotion is named after Andre Charon
who is a French study composer he uh
actually is behind a lot of the ideas
that we now take for granted in King
Knight versus King Pawn end games and
yes a white has a knight this is
Sharon's composition he invented this
idea I want to say around the 1920s or
30s but he was composing a lot of night
end game studies for really for dozens
of years this is definitely his most
famous and this is an idea which occurs
very frequently in tournament practice
so so not only is it really beautiful
and unique but it's also super important
we will see it make several appearances
in the next video the goal here is to
win the game with the white pieces that
may sound absurd because the pawn was
not only is it on the fifth rank but
it's it's restrained by the night what
on Earth can we possibly do here once
again pause the video and try to solve
this simple but really beautiful study
okay so hopefully as you were able to
find the solution starts with the Knight
to G7 check sacrificing the Knight if
black doesn't take it then you take
blacks Knight and you keep the pawn
protected black has to take of course
next you push the pawn and as we've
already discussed this would be an easy
win if the Knight moves if the Knight
moves then you play H7 and the Knight
has nowhere to move in order to then
jump onto one of the two squares from
which it can control the promotion
Square for example Knight F5 H7 and it's
easy to see
that uh the pawn promotes on the next
move I can give a check but it's it's
totally meaningless
same goes for 96 and Knight H5 but there
seems to be an extenuating circumstance
Black's King is very close to the H Pawn
and black can seemingly make the draw
with King to F7 you have to take the
Knight and then black takes the pawn
back and the game is over it's a draw
and this is where charon's Brilliance
really shines white plays the move H7
and look at this position carefully
despite the proximity of Black's King
this is such a nice optical illusion you
think there's no way the pawn can
promote both the blacks pieces are right
next to it and yet this really
illustrates like nothing else the
awkwardness of the Knight when it comes
to stopping particularly Corner past
pawns if the Knight isn't on the right
Square then it's totally helpless on G7
it's on the worst Square on the
chessboard it's right next to the pawn
but it can't stop the promotion square
and neither can the King which is
blocked by the Knight and blocked by The
Pawn on the next move white makes a
queen just I would pause the video here
just look at this position for a couple
of seconds and make sure you're
convinced that that on is able to
promote so this may seem like an
outlandish bizarre idea that only occurs
in you know compositions but no it
actually occurs pretty frequently in
night end games and so this is the
position I wanted to start with when it
comes to winning the game uh when you've
when you're on the side uh that is
playing against the Knight
okay so the next scenario I want to talk
about is one in which the king dominates
the Knight and again we're still talking
about one side having a king and only
one pawn and the other side having a
king a knight and no pawns uh we're
gonna add some pawns for both sides as
as we go along so it's important to
understand that not only is it important
where your pass Pawn is located but the
positioning of the Knight is also
critical there are situations when you
when despite the the relatively uh far
back nature of the pawn the pawn here is
only on H4 it seems the black has ample
time to stop it with his Knight
the situation changes because your king
is uniquely positioned to dominate the
knight's crucial squares so what you do
not want to do here with white is play
the move H5 and you can use your
knowledge to determine that if you play
H5 which is Hasty black drops the Knight
back to E6 and guess what after H6
Knight fa check we get exactly the
position that we discussed the pawn is
only on the sixth Rank and black is able
to make the draw you should know this by
now King g796 check
Etc what you want to do instead in this
position to win the game is take away
the Knights key uh retreating squares
because without access to E6 and F5 the
Knight has no way to get into the Zone
where it will be able to stop the H Pawn
so paradoxically after King F6 white
wins the game white wins the game
because the H Pawn is simply free to
promote and there is absolutely nothing
the Knight can do and I won't give too
many lines again you are welcome to set
this up and analyze yourself I will give
one very instructive line the dominant
Nation continues black can try a very
devious idea black and go Knight F3
white pushes H5 and black goes to H2
right the Knight is such a unique piece
because this is the only thing it can do
it can actually go the other way in
order to try to stop the pawn and again
you should see why H6 is wrong the
Knight steps back to G4 forking the king
of the pawn and black secures the drop
but part two of the domination is to
step your king back to F5 once again
taking away the knights only good Square
the G4 square and finally the pawn is
able to promote for instance Knight F1
H6 black can give a completely
meaningless check on G3 so you play King
2g6
and on the next move uh you play H7 and
then h8 92 H7 black can give another
meaningless checking at this point you
can do many different things the best uh
move to play is King F7 so notice here
that the king and the Knight are three
squares away and that is a very
effective position to be in if you're
the king because you're controlling the
knights to critical or retreating
squares E6 uh and G6 so if we rewind
back to the start this is an important
situation to imprint in your memory you
can kind of uh create a mental reference
point in your mind where yeah the king
is diagonally one square away from the
Knight but there are many situations in
which the king is able to dominate The
Knight what I suggest is that you take
away the key concept which is that you
can use your king to take away to
deprive the Knight of squares that it
has to go to in order to stop a past
pawn and the kind of corollary to that
is that when you've got a pass Pawn uh
yes your default is to push it but
sometimes investing that extra tempo uh
to prevent the knight from reaching
important squares is the difference
between a win and a loss after King F6
white wins the game and obviously
Black's King is way too far away
so let me check my notes here to see if
I have any other positions I want to get
to where the side with the pawns wins
the game yes there is one and again we
are going to start with a position in
which one side does have a knight so
technically this starts out as a night
end game uh but ultimately it still
demonstrates the superiority of past
pawns over the night so we are actually
going to flip the board here because
this comes from a real game this comes
from a real game from the 1920s it is
black to play and yes again we we start
with a night end game we start in a
scenario where both sides have the
Knight but you will quickly see what it
is that I am trying to illustrate with
this example now not only are past pawns
incredibly strong when it comes to
overwhelming the Knight when you've got
two of them when you've got connected
passers uh supported by a king that can
overwhelm a rook and the Knight is often
completely helpless when it comes to
facing an army composed of a king that
is supporting two pawns that are on
adjacent files and so if you kind of
know that then the winning idea in this
position should be very very easy to
spot it's black to play see if you can
pause the video and figure out a way to
quickly and efficiently break down
White's resistance
okay I've got I've got several beverages
here that I can help myself to as I
think of all the people torturing
themselves over this position
so what makes this a little bit trickier
I think is the presence of the H2 Pawn
this is kind of a red herring in the
sense that I can kind of see a case
being made for an idea that involves
um for an idea oh sorry it is uh White
to move but that changes absolutely
nothing
um in the game white played Knight T1
everything that you thought about still
applies in fact even more so so I could
see a case being made for King E5 and
trying to go King F4 and King G3 Etc the
problem is that the win here is a lot
trickier to achieve after Knight B2 if
you play King F4 white can step up with
King G2 right if white plays D6 then
your idea Works to Perfection you go
King G3 and then you check made on F2
but white can go King G2
and you can't go any further and if you
go the other way well it's very easy to
let the pawn forward to D6 and here
black is actually still winning but
things get a lot more complicated than
they should be in the game black was
able to find a much simpler method of
winning the first step is to bring your
knight back to E5 and after Knight B2 a
very straightforward tactic wins the
game you sacrifice your knight for the
C4 Pawn then you take the pawn on T5
this H2 Pawn is totally irrelevant you
would win the game without it in exactly
the same way and the pawns and the King
totally overwhelmed the Knight that is
very easy to see does it matter where
the Knight goes you pre-move C4
and all the Knight can do here is
temporarily halt the progression this is
actually why having your king is really
important notice that if Black's King
were you know somewhere on h8 the pawns
are not able to see themselves through
the promotion so the Knight can't
actually blockade two uh or even in some
rare situations three pass pawns but if
they're supported by the king then uh
seeing them through is very easy you
play King D4 notice again the king
dominates the Knight but that doesn't
matter the point is to play C3 and you
can actually choose which Pawn to
promote C2 or B2 on the next move and
you're gonna make at least one and
probably two queens so uh the the
operative concept here is uh sacrificing
in many cases your knight with the
understanding that two pass pawns
supported by the king in most cases are
able to overwhelm the Knight okay now we
move on to a set of positions in which
you are the side that has the king and
uh the pawn or pawns and you are trying
to make a draw against the Knight and
first of all we're going to discuss a
scenario where all you have is a king
there are a couple of very important
positions where you only have a king and
you're facing a knight and a pawn and
it's actually still a draw these are
also theoretical positions uh which are
very important to know and let us start
with what I call the imprisoned King
draw and the imprisoned King draw is
really one of my favorite uh positions
within the subset of end games because
if you don't know it your intuition is
screaming in One Direction and yet the
evaluation is screaming in the other if
you turn on the chess.com engine by the
way it's giving plus five that's a
meaningless evaluation because this is a
draw and whether it is a draw or a win
depends on which side is to move uh
we're taking black side here because
black is the side trying to make a draw
white is going toward us White's Pawn is
going forward so the king is currently
blocking the pawn and with white to move
this position is a draw even though yes
white has a knight on defense 5.
why is it a draw with white to move and
why is it a win with black to move well
it's actually pretty easy to understand
with white to play he has to move the
Knight The King has no squares the
moment the Knight goes back the King has
access to the C7 square and The crucial
thing to remember is that a knight does
not have the capacity to lose a Tempo
you essentially cannot engineer
the initial position with the other side
to move you can do that with the King
via triangulation a Technique we saw in
the pawn end game video you can do that
with a bishop right if you had a bishop
on H2 you could just play Bishop G3
essentially the Knight cannot stand in
place while controlling the same square
the bishop Can it can move along a
diagonal and it's easy to see that no
matter how hard you try you're going to
keep running into the scenario where
you're controlling the C7 square but you
have to move your knight away from it it
doesn't matter Knight B8 of course white
can try Knight C7 this is the only trick
that you really can try if you're the
side of the night
of course don't take and allow the king
back just keep going King C8 King C7
even if you have two seconds on the
clock this is easy to draw because you
can pre-move King C7 and King C8 nothing
that white can do about it now obviously
if we rewind to our initial position if
it is black to play then black is in
zugspawn white control C7 the King has
to step away and White's King goes to B7
or B8 and white promotes the pawn so
another one of those super powerful
theoretical positions that you can aim
for as part of a larger defensive
strategy and again we will come across
this end game in our next video the
second really cool type of draw involves
a knight and a corner Pawn on the
seventh rank again but this time we
essentially flip uh the positioning of
the Kings so let's examine this position
in which White's King is no longer boxed
in White's Pawn is still on the seventh
rank it's still going toward us and it's
protected by a knight this position is a
draw with either side decided to move
and it's a draw for much the same reason
that a bishop and a pawn a corner Pawn
of the wrong promotion color is a draw
we'll talk about that in a subsequent
video when we discuss bishop and games
it's because every time white tries to
approach Black's King it's stalemate and
white is no other way to make progress
right King B6 is stalemate King A6 is
stalemate if white steps back then black
toggles between B7 and A8 the moment the
Knight moves white loses the A7 Pawn
doesn't matter how white tries to
approach Black's King if you try to go
from the side you're gonna keep running
into the same exact thing this situation
same thing King C7 or King C8 both of
those moves result in stalemate if the
Knight moves black immediately captures
the pawn and as you know King and Knight
vs king is a draw no matter you can't
even hypothetically set up a Checkmate
so the defending side here is able to
make a draw doesn't matter whose move it
is uh because the side with a knight in
the pawn are not able to make progress
that is why when we take uh the side of
the night we will discuss a scenario
where you push the pawn back one file to
A6 that is an end game that a lot of
people get Wrong by pre uh by hastily
pushing the pawn to the seventh Rank and
then realizing wait a second I've got an
extra Knight in a pawn and I can't win
this
okay
so let me see if I have any other
uh illustrations of using the pawn to
draw I think that's it and I think we
are going to now take the side of the
night yes
um no one more there is one more
scenario that I wish to talk about and
this is a little bit more advanced but
no less important this is a defensive
mechanism that can allow you to save uh
some positions that look incredibly lost
and I'll show you some beautiful
examples of this in action in the next
position okay so this concept doesn't
refer only to one position it refers to
a type of position in which one side has
a knight and a pawn and the other side
has only a pawn and a king and yet it is
still a draw that I refer to as the
opposition draw because the side with
the Knight is essentially not able to
get out of uh the awkward construction
and move the king to the right spot
while keeping the pawn defended so in
this position it is white to play and
you can see a similar thing to what we
just saw where the Knight is linked to
the pawn so the Knight must remain on F4
White's goal would be to essentially
push the black king to shoulder the
black king out of G5 and it seems pretty
Elementary and a bygone conclusion that
white can kind of go around with his
King and maybe even sacrifice the knight
in the end but ultimately get to the H6
Pawn but watch what actually happens
white starts with King F3 that's the
only move which makes sense now the
amazing thing here is that the move King
F5 As Natural as it seems actually loses
the game you cannot lose contact and
this is the key thing to remember you
cannot lose contact with the H fund the
moment you do the Knight moves on to a
better spot in this case it moves back
to H3 guarding the G5 square and now
white can essentially initiate the
process of shouldering King G4 and
whichever way the black king goes white
king uh gathers more territory King F6
King F4 Etc and if black maintains the
opposition the prettiest and fastest way
to win is actually the night sack on G5
HG H6 and if the king steps back it's
too late the Knight picks up the H Pawn
and that as you will see is an easy win
as long as the H Pawn as long as your
corner Pawn is not on the seventh rank
uh the side of the Knight wins straight
forward so rewinding back to this
position I called it the opposition draw
because the kings are initially in
opposition but you don't maintain your
opposition uh unless
you can simultaneously maintain contact
with the pawn and we see that scenario
here King H4
let's say that white tries King E3 here
you can claim opposition and maintain
contact with the Pawn King G4 does draw
but the prettiest draw is in the most
conceptual draw is King to G5
maintaining diagonal opposition from our
Pawn end game video and after King E4
you keep opposition with King G4 white
is on the cusp of reaching the promised
land on F6 but no you step back to G5
and there is nothing that white can do
white moves the Knight you win the pawn
white steps back you step back you go
Ring Around the Rosie the only trick
that white has in the bag is King to E6
and this kind of idea does win some
games where you sack the Knight and
distract the king and now go King F6 but
do not be fooled by the appearance of
this position it is still a draw and
black makes it by circling around with
the king king E4 King G6 and black is in
time to reach not the h8 or G8 square
but that's not the only way to draw you
can draw by playing King F6 another end
game that we came across in the pawn and
game video this is why I I recommend
that you watch the end game videos in
order because they build on each other
as we add pieces remember that things do
keep liquidating to pawn end games that
is why you should start your endgame
journey by really learning uh the
substrates and the key tenets upon end
games that gives you the power uh to
really approach the other end games uh
as a knowledgeable student of the end
game this is a draw because you keep the
white king uh locked on the H file
so amazingly this position is actually a
draw with white to move now if it is
black to move let me triangulate the
white king uh so I'm not take these
moves with a grain of salt I'm just
trying to get the same position so that
chess.com allows me uh to move to move
black so we want to do this we want to
do this and we want to do this with
black to play this position is lost and
you should already know why it is
because you have to lose contact with
the H5 Pawn you have to go King F5 and
again white does this thing where he
goes Knight to H3 preventing King G5 and
then White's King starts to claim
territory and ultimately uh the Knight
is able to circle around and win the H
Pawn or black gets uh black gets
shouldered in the event that black just
goes back uh you do what you do in a
pawn end game right you shoulder the
black king now obviously without the
Knight this is a draw because King and H
Pawn versus King is always a drama with
the Knight on the board uh this is an
elementary win
um so something to remember in some
situations you can draw the game with
only a king and a pawn by keeping the
white king at Bay and maintaining
contact with your opponent's only
remaining Pawn this doesn't only occur
with a corner Pawn but in most cases uh
of practical play this is where you see
this type of drawing we will see it
again so don't feel like you have to
understand this a hundred percent I'm
kind of giving you the conceptual
substrates in this video and in the next
video we take a look at a more
complicated and actual practical
applications of all of these end games
now we take the side of the night and we
discuss a couple of important positions
in which the side that has the Knight
and or pawns uh is able to win the game
we start with uh one of my favorite
theoretical positions we flip the board
again now we take white side where the
Knight and the King are actually able to
mate Black's King and this is a
situation which only arises when one
side has a corner pawn and then a king
that is essentially locked out by that
Corner Pawn so you might say well isn't
King and Knight versus King always a
draw it is but when you add this Pawn to
A3 this is actually a win for white and
white is able to forcibly Checkmate The
Black Gang in one of the prettiest end
game mating constructions this position
is actually a composition from I think
the 1600s there was a guy named salvio
Italian early Italian chess master
Alessandro salvio wrote one of the
earliest chess books and he already
discovered this type of endgame
construction very impressive pause the
video Let's see if you can solve this
salvio study it is white to play and
mate in five moves
okay so the first step here and there
are two moves that achieve this is to
prevent the black king from escaping via
B3 if it does then whites winning you
can bid goodbye to your winning chances
so you start with a logical move King C2
and after King A1 you have to do what is
called building a Target position I
mentioned that word earlier in the video
um a Target position is essentially the
position that you ultimately want to
reach this allows you to guide your
calculation in the right direction if
you just randomly Shuffle the Knight
around you're not just gonna stumble on
the right mating construction so first
let's ask ourselves under what
circumstances will we be able to
Checkmate the black king what is the
actual mating position what do we need
to get well it's not hard to determine
that you what you need to do is force
the black pawn to A2 and at that very
moment the Knight has to be able to jump
to the mating Square B3 and there are a
couple of similar mating constructions
for instance the white king could be on
C1 and then the White Knight could be on
C2
but since the king is on C2 the most
feasible made in construction uh is the
black Pawn on A2 and the White Knight on
B3 now let's reverse engineer this well
what has to happen in order for black to
be forced to push the pawn to A2 where
does White's Knight have to be such that
a black cannot play King A2 and B black
has to therefore play the move A2 and C
the Knight has access to the B3 Square
so find a square on the board that
satisfies all three of those conditions
there's actually only one and that
square ladies and gentlemen is C1 you
guide your knight towards c195 King A2
if A2 then we get the position
immediately now you want to avoid Knight
to B3 that would be stalemate a lot of
people they just forget about this when
the king is confined like this you
always have to make sure that you're
leaving the king with squares no you go
Knight to D3 King to A1 and now the
promised land is reached not night
before which only satisfies the first
condition and allows black to play A2
you can't reach B3 you have to go
specifically to see
the king is cut off from A2 black has to
play Pawn A2 and Knight P3 is Checkmate
and again your reaction to this might be
well that's pretty but why do I have to
know this and you have to know this
because it actually does occur in
Practical play it also is a great
illustration that just because you have
one minor piece left doesn't mean that
you can't Checkmate the opponent mate is
possible in almost any position you
should be aware of that and as we
progress to Rook end games and
ultimately Queen end games a big
component of our learning is going to be
developing our antenna for sudden end
game attacks which are some of my
favorite uh combinations in mating
attacks when you have only one piece or
two pieces and they're able to combine
miraculously to Checkmate the king here
you need a little bit of help but
remember that a situation where the king
is locked in by its Corner Pawn isn't
necessarily A draw yes the Knight has
mating capability okay let's move on
and talk about uh continuing to use the
knight in order to win the game I want
to next discuss a very important
construction that involves a knight and
a past Pawn when you have a knight and a
pass pawn and you're facing a lone King
and of course again remember this is
purely theoretical so when you're
looking at this position it's an
important position to know in and of
itself but you could modify it a little
bit and things would still remain the
same for instance you could add a black
pawn to G7 here and as you will see
nothing will change because ultimately
you can use the white king to stop the
black pawn here we're talking about the
conceptual component which is what I
refer to as the ideal Knight Pawn
formation
so what white is trying to do here is
ensure that black is unable to capture
White's last Pawn which would result in
an immediate draw and the question is
where do you want to keep your knight
the answer is very simple in most cases
when you're trying to support a pass
Pawn you want to keep your knight behind
the past Pawn you want to defend the
pawn from behind so that when the Knight
is captured by the enemy King your Pawn
is able to push forward uh and the king
is unable to stop it so a big mistake
here would be to say hey I'm defending
the pawn let's bring our King in King G2
wrong wrong wrong Black Goes King B4 you
can't move the Knight you have to move
your king black is able to capture the
Knight and then come back for the pawn
because the king is on the right side so
pause the video and figure out where the
Knight belongs so that when the king
captures it the b-pawn is able to rush
forward to promotion
thank you
okay so the answer is D2 and I have to
give credit to mark varetsky this is one
of the instructive positions from his
chapter on King Knight versus King pawns
all white has to do is go Knight C4 King
B4 and Knight D2 just sear this
construction into your mind and the
point is after King C3 this is
self-sufficient you don't have to
address it anymore now we can bring our
King up and the moment black captures
the Knight the b-pawn rushes forward and
Black's King is obviously unable to stop
and of course black should Shuffle back
and forth but now white has all the time
in the world
to bring up the king and ultimately
support this Pawn to promotion and most
King Knight Pawn versus King positions
are incredibly easy to win uh with the
services of your night that's why we
talked about the corner Pawn on the
seventh scenario which is a very rare
exception
now on that topic we also should discuss
the situation in which one side has a
knight and a pawn but that corner Pawn
is now on the sixth rank right so a draw
uh is reached if the pawn is on the
seventh and it's defended by the Knight
we talked about that a little bit
earlier what if you shift the pawn one
square back well first of all what you
do not want to do is stalemate the king
with Knight C6 another very common thing
that happens especially in time pressure
the second thing you do not want to do
is push the pawn prematurely up to A7 so
an example of that would be king B6 King
B8 and now A7 would be a grave error
because after King to a a there is no
way to keep the pawn protected while
avoiding stalemate and even if the
Knight was on C6 here it wouldn't matter
because the king could step away yes but
then you would reach the theoretical
draw that we discussed a little bit
earlier all you have to know about
winning this position is that you have
to position the knight in such a way
that it cuts the king off from A8 and
the best Square to do that is the C7
Square the win is achieved with Knight
to D5
it doesn't matter where the King goes
again not A7 with stalemate Knight C7
check is simple King B8 the square is
under control and now you can push the
pawn to A7 so you need the support of
both the King which guards the pawn and
the Knight and the Knight which deprives
the the enemy King of the A8 Square then
you promote to a queen and what's
actually good to know if you're in
severe time pressure if you're in a Time
scramble there is a Checkmate in two
moves from this position which is very
common because you often get this exact
type of position which is Queen E8 check
and then Queen to E6 with a very elegant
Checkmate so this is good to know if
you've got one second left on your clock
you can pre-move all of these moves
starting with Knight C7 and you can win
the game now again the move order is
pretty flexible
um you can play
95 King C8 and you can do this in
several ways if it were black to move
here it would not matter if it were
black to move here you could still play
A7 check Force the king into the corner
and then checkmated on C7 all that you
have to remember is that the Knight
belongs on the C7 Square in order to
deprive the black king of the ability to
shuffle between A8 and B8 white wins in
elementary fashion
okay and finally we move on to scenarios
in which you use your knight in order to
make a draw
you're facing a bunch of bloodthirsty
puns what are the important defensive
techniques that you have to know well
the first one and the perhaps the most
important one is using checks in order
to stop the pawn and we start with an
elementary illustration of this concept
and then we're going to take a look at
one other example that has a little bit
more meat on the bone because this is so
important examine this position with
white to move now we've already talked
about a bunch of these scenarios the big
question is whether the Knight can stop
that H Pawn before it reaches the second
Rank and you might look at this and say
well no there isn't right you can start
with Knight F5 black plays H3 and then
black pre-moves H2 and you lose Knight
G3 H2 and you already know how to win
this black just approaches the Knight
and then locks it up on H1 but this is
where the technique comes into play the
Knight is a pretty tricky piece it might
be very bad at stopping past pawns but
it's got some tricks up its sleeve and
one of them is to deliver a well-timed
check to the enemy King in order to
bring itself to a more desirable
position and the Knight can do that here
with a check on E3 because of the
awkward positioning of Black's King the
Knight is able to Circle to Circle over
to G4 and stop the pawn in time and
again as I said at the start you can now
see that a lot of these positions
ultimately get into one of the
theoretical positions we started with uh
with or without other pawns and pieces
and so knowing the evaluation is very
important whether you're trying to
winner trying to draw here you achieve
the draw we talked about this already
several times the night uh is able to
circle circle around and keep the pawn
at Bay so white draws by using a check
to stop the pawn let's look at this idea
in the wild let's add some pieces on the
board this is a real game between two
very strong players in the 1930s and in
this position it is white to play so let
us flip the board because we are going
to be defending from the black side and
I know that when I flip the board it can
it can take you a moment to adjust your
eyes to where the pawns are going but as
I said in an earlier video that is an
important skill right you shouldn't just
roll your eyes and say well now I don't
know where the pawns are going you
should be able to orient yourself in any
position pretty quickly and it's good to
get practice in that realm so black of
course is now going forward and white is
going toward the eighth rank so white
comes up with a devious scheme he plays
the move Knight F4 and we talked about a
concept like this you sacrifice your
knight in order to pave the way for a
past Pawn in an earlier instantiation we
talked about sacking the Knight for an
opponent's pawns here you sack the
knight in order to deflect the enemy
knight from its control over a key
Square an idea that we will come across
in the next video as well and black
decides to do something ridiculous black
actually takes the Knight on F4 this
look looks like a grave mistake because
white plays G7 and the pawn is now
Unstoppable and what's important here is
that although black has two past pawns
which are far Advanced
um black doesn't seem to be able to
promote them now what's amazing
uh is that black has an alternative draw
in this position which is incredibly
instructive an alternative to the main
draw that we are using to highlight this
theme and we are actually going to get
to that draw a little bit later so we
will come back to this position and
discuss the secondary draw but first
let's see if you can find a way to apply
the concept can you use a series of
well-timed checks against White's King
in order to navigate your knight to the
proper spot and stop the g-pawn pause
the video and see if you can figure it
out
foreign
so the first step is to push the pawn up
to D3 this forces the white king to
capture C3 otherwise of course black
promotes his own pawns now the king is
on a vulnerable spot it's on a checking
spot you go Knight C5 check
and the Knight is able to make it to E7
enter in time or F6 that works as well
but there's one more important thing to
remember white plays H5 and white
threatens to overwhelm the Knight with
the connected passers but as I had
mentioned earlier the Knight is able to
fight a pair of connected passers as
long as the opposing side's King isn't
able to support them and here black
earns himself just enough time to
generate drawing counter play with the
aid of this additional Apon white
approaches with his King now a an
instructive mistake would be to play
Knight F6 check oh I've spotted a fork
well white has two Pawn so capturing one
of them doesn't help white promotes the
other no black needs to get down to
business on the other side and black is
actually just in time here King back
King G6 you push A3 white pushes H6 and
the pawn race results in a draw the most
clinical move here is actually to avoid
A2 because after H7 white keeps the
extra Pawn on G7 this is still a draw
but there's no need for or you know for
these Shenanigans you actually want to
just take on H6 and after King takes H6
A2 G8 A1 Black promotes at the same time
and as you remember from the pawn race
video you have to double check that
there are no skewers that there are no
pins there are none here the king and
the queen are in good spots and black is
able to secure the draw so the key thing
to remember here
uh is that by the way King B3 is also a
draw even the white promotes with check
at the end of the line this is something
we will get to in a later video when you
have a corner Pawn on the second rank
against a queen that is still a
theoretical drop but it's unnecessary
um but the the key part of this example
is how black actually uses two checks
the first one with the pawn but the
second one with the Knight to navigate
his way towards stopping the pawn this
is a game-changing defensive technique
that you have to remember
because it allows you to save so many
positions that otherwise uh you would
have had to
allow the pawn to promote now we will
talk about the alternate draw here in
just a moment first uh I want to expose
the overall technique and then we will
come back to this position the technique
is what I refer to as we flip the board
one more time here as using the Knight
and Pawn in order to draw against the
enemy Queen so this is a situation in
which you have a king a knight and
either a pawn or several Pawns and
unfortunately the Knight is unable to
stop the enemy passer and the second
unfortunate thing is that it seems that
you are unable to use your own past
pawns uh to promote to your own Queen in
time
now as you can see here the Knight is
essentially on the worst possible Square
uh where it it simply cannot stop the A4
Pawn from progressing to a queen so the
first thing to point out is that it
doesn't matter where you move your
knight you can play Knight t7 black
plays A3 and you're not even close like
you just can't reach the a the a pawn 95
A2 uh and black promotes on the next
move Knight C5 check you take it uh but
by the way even if there was no Pawn on
B6 using the technique of dominating the
Knight with the King uh you should be
able to come up with the move King to C4
cutting off the knight from the key B3
Square then you play A2 but there is a
Pawn on B6 and that's unnecessary
so why is unable to stop the pawn that
much is clear but you may find a sliver
of Hope in the fact that you have your
own past Pawn on D4 okay so that pawn
can be pushed and white did push it in
the game D5 the problem is that it's not
fast enough and in the pawn race the
king is in the checking Zone to borrow a
term from the pond race video of Black's
newly minted Queen darnette black
promotes with check and most importantly
uh wherever the King goes the the queen
is able to contain the pawn and in some
cases actually even win the Knight for
example King E7 Queen E5 check black
picks up the Knight and simultaneously
stops the pawn from promotion King E6 is
a little bit trickier but what black
does here is essentially zigzags his
Queen check Queen D2 this is kind of the
staircase mechanism that you have to
remember and ultimately you reach a
situation in which white has to play
King F7 or King D6 and in either case
black is able to pick up the Knight
and after King E7 what you should notice
is that Queen takes B8 immediately would
be a mistake because white can still
promote and make a draw black should
give this additional check on E5 this is
the power of the queen tossing the king
away from the promotion Square then you
take the Knight and you win the game in
elementary fashion but what's amazing is
that white can actually draw and white
can draw it with what may seem like an
incredibly counter-intuitive idea you
have to
hold yourself back from further progress
of the deep pawn and burn a Tempo on
positioning your knight on a square that
it from which it will be able to support
the pawn once it reaches D7 so the
shocking move that white finds in the
game is Knight B8 to C6 are you trying
to stop the a pawn not at all here's
what you're trying to do and it even
takes the engine a couple of moments to
realize the Brilliance of the scheme
black plays A2 now you throw in another
check on D4 and the point is that if the
King goes back to C2 C4 White's Knight
moves to C2 and after King takes D5 you
Fork the pawn and win and white wins the
game because white still has pawns on
the king side so that's not good and if
wet black goes back to C3 the Knight
buries itself on A1 and then white is
able to promote the pawn just in time
and white is in very good shape still a
draw but this time black is on the
defensive side Okay so
as we rewind to this position the king
of course has to go to B2 and only now
does white push the pawn if the King by
the way goes to A3
uh then white moves up to F7 and look at
this position remember it forks forks
Galore A1 Queen Knight C2 picks up the
queen and white wins so black actually
has to go to B2 to prevent all the
Knight Forks again it's that diagonal
situation where the king is one square
away from the Knight diagonally but now
white pushes the pawn and after A1 Queen
D7 you can see why you forced the king
to B2 the Knight is Untouchable white
threatens to promote and this is the
main theoretical concept why did we go
through all of the trouble to get the
Knight back around to T4 remember that
we had a similar position with the
Knight on B8 but B8 is a terrible Square
the Knight is vulnerable on that square
the only way for black to stop the pawn
is Queen to A8 and here you can dive
into E6 with your knight reaching a very
important defensive construction even
though black is a queen up the combined
force of the Knight the king and the
pawn allow white to draw because black
simply cannot make progress black cannot
stop the pawn or win the Knight all
black can do is continuously check the
white king ad nauseum and make a draw
Queen takes F3 uh King E5
queen king E7 by the way is a mistake
because if Queen takes H3 this is a cool
detail why promotes but black trades the
queens and you can see how complicated
these end games can get and trousers
which we talked about in pawn and give
it is are especially bad because the
Knight can only control one pass Pawn at
the same time so it's easy to see that
this is winning for black white has to
be incredibly careful but this is less
important what's more important is the
general concept of using the knight in
the past Pawn to keep the queen at Bay
and ultimately black can continue to
check but black is never going to be
able uh to prevent the pawn from
promoting and if black tries the same
technique here white is able to draw
because the white king is actually no
King C6 is wrong because black trades
and plays H4 you need to go the other
way
and you assign jobs here you say well
King I want you to stop the corner Pawn
Knight I want you to stop the bee Pawn
B5 Knight C6 H4 King F4 both pieces are
able to fulfill their tasks uh and white
is able to eke out a draw so a really
important technique a more advanced
technique so just because your opponent
is promoting doesn't mean you should
Panic as a last resort you can drive
your Pawn up to the seventh or sometimes
even the sixth Rank and because of the
power of the Knight to control certain
key squares you're able to achieve
what's called a positional draw
positional draw is a situation in which
it's not stalemate it's a situation in
which one side is essentially unable to
make progress okay now as our final
example let's come back to the position
that we had just analyzed uh where you
use checks to stop the pawn after Knight
F4 let's flip the board so we're facing
Black Knight takes F4 G7 there is an
alternative draw let's see if you can
use your newfound knowledge and find
find that alternative draw remember that
the draw we talked about first was to
use checks in order to stop the pawn all
right I'll give you a second to think
here
okay so the answer is actually the
paradoxical King to B4
and after G8 Queen D3 you would be
forgiven for thinking that black can
promote a pawn by force but no he cannot
King C1 would be a gray Vera this would
allow black to give a check on E2 and
promote the C Pawn but white can step
back to B1
and hey if you play C2 check white plays
King B2 then black loses black can't
promote the pawn and yet this is still a
draw it's a draw after a 92 because
white again simply cannot make progress
white cannot pick off the C Pawn by
force because it's protected by T3 and
all that white can do is helplessly
deliver a bunch of checks Queen B a
check Queen C7 check it doesn't matter
actually where you even go with your
king you can go anywhere King C4 E43
doesn't matter white just has to keep
checking and there's no way for white to
make progo even King F3 the Knight of
the pawn are self-sufficient the only
thing you can do to lose is play King G3
and give up the D3 Pawn with Jack as
long as you avoid that white can make
zero progress in this position so this
is our final defensive technique in
terms of using the Knight actually there
is one more I forgot there is one more
position I want to get to but the
concept here is using the knight in the
pawn to keep the opponent's Queen at Bay
okay the final position that I want to
talk about here
and let me see if I actually put it in
using checks to stop the pawn Corner
Pawn on the sixth win
Corner Pawn on the seventh draw no
that's not this one I might have
forgotten
uh to to put this in corner Pawn draw
yes no I did not forget to put it in
it's this one this is going to be our
final position and our final defensive
technique uh with the side that has the
Knight video has been going an hour so
thank you if you're still with me
okay final position I promise it is
white to play here and this might seem
to be exactly the same position that we
started our Exploration with we started
Remember by discussing what happens when
the pawn reaches the seventh Rank and
you might say well now I know that this
is a win for white white approaches the
Knight reaches C6 and then traps the
Knight on A8 but as a last resort there
is one defensive technique that is easy
to forget about and the concept is you
actually move the Knight to A8 and you
can even do it here you move the Knight
into the corner and if your king is
close enough then you can Dash your king
toward the side with the pawn and lock
your opponent's king in the corner in
the position We examined initially the
black king was on H1 and I teased this
by saying that the black king is one
tempo short here the king starts out on
G2 so Watch What Happens Black Goes King
F3 Black Goes King E4 King E5 and the
rub is that black is in time to reach
the C7 square and stalemate the white
King on A8 so this is a very simple idea
to follow but it's easy to forget about
In the Heat of the Moment not only are
you able to draw if your king is
physically able to eliminate the pawn
but there is one silver lining to your
opponent having the corner pawn and that
is that if the king captures the Knight
it is locked in by its own pawn and you
are able to use the king in some
circumstances to stalemate the white
king so those are our defensive
techniques when you have the Knight and
that concludes my Whirlwind presentation
of the key theoretical positions you
have to know uh in cane Knight versus
King Pawn end games let's do a very very
quick summary
um before we close off and again there
will be a follow-up video in which we
look at a bunch of practical examples so
right now yeah you should be feeling
like you know I get the concepts but I
want to see some examples I want to see
actual positions with a knight and a lot
of Pawns against a lot of Pawns right we
most mostly focused on one side having
one Pawn or no pawns but again bear with
me these theoretical foundations are
going to help you tremendously and
without them it's impossible to orient
yourself in more complicated positions
so first We examined every situation in
which the pawn reaches the seventh rank
it's generally a win with a corner Pawn
as long as the king is far enough away
with the Knight Pawn as well as the
other pawns it's always a draw but the
key thing about having a night Pawn is
that the king can continuously pursue
the Knight and essentially force a draw
with the bishop pawn and the center
pawns you can't do that we then examine
situations in which the side of the pawn
is abled or the pawns is able to
overwhelm the Knight we talked about the
share on promotion we talked about the
king dominating the Knight even if the
pass Pawn is rather far away and then we
talked about sacrificing the knight in
order to win the game where two pass
pawns overwhelm the Knight then we
talked about a bunch of drawing
scenarios if you are the side with the
King and or pawns we talked about the
theoretical draw in which the pawn is in
the corner white cannot make progress we
talked about the imprisoned King draw in
which white also cannot make progress
because the Knight cannot lose the tempo
uh and we also talked about the
opposition draw in which again white
cannot make progress the key here is to
maintain contact with the pawn then we
transition to uh to having the Knight
and using the Knight to win we talked
about the salvio study in which you can
actually Checkmate uh you can actually
Checkmate the black king with only a
bare Knight let me find it here uh
sacrificing Knight to win Knight makes
Corner Pawn this is the salvio study
very common Concept in Practical play as
well uh we talked about the ideal Knight
Pawn formation which you want to keep
the Knight behind the past Pawn so that
if the king captures it uh so that if
the king captures it you are able to
promote the pawn
then we talked about drawing mechanisms
when you are the side with the Knight
um we talked about using checks to stop
the pawn sometimes you can't stop the
pawn directly but you can use a
well-timed check against the king this
was our other example and then we talked
about
um we talked about using the Knight Plus
Pawn to fight the opponent's Queen and
that can still be a draw if your pass
Pawn is sufficiently far Advanced uh the
final thing I forgot to mention uh is
the scenario where the corner Pawn is on
the sixth rank which is still
paradoxically a draw because the Knight
is able to use the concept of the fork
to keep the pawn uh at Bay once it
reaches the seventh Rank and then we
ended with that position where you're
able to sack your knight and bring your
king in order to lock your opponent's
king in the corner in time and that
ladies and gentlemen is what I have for
you today this was over an hour I know
that was a long time but I really wanted
to get through all of those key
theoretical positions this doesn't come
close to covering it there are a lot of
other important positions that I omitted
and these end game videos are not
totally exhaustive but in the next video
we are going to not only recap some of
these important theoretical substrates
but through the lens of what I really
feel like are some beautiful practical
examples that I've uncovered and that
are very much unknown you are going to
get a finer understanding for how to
handle both the Knight and the pawns and
we're going to talk about a bunch of
more Advanced Techniques well thank you
for listening everybody I know these end
game videos are pretty dense but it's
really a pleasure to make them
um and I want to make this the premier
resource for endgame learning for
players of all levels hopefully I'm
doing a halfway decent job so far on
that note I will see you in the next
video I will get to work preparing
examples and whether you're the side of
the night or the side with the pawn good
luck in your end game Journey I will see
you in the next video thank you for
watching
foreign
[Music]